in Norse mythology there are many great
beasts and monsters that many of them
pale in comparison to your demand in Old
Norse your men ganda meant great beasts
and he was commonly referred to as the
Midgard serpent because his body was so
big that it couldn't circle the entire
of Midgard yeoman gand was one of the
three children of Loki and along with
his brother and sister Helen Fenrir
their fate was decided when they were
born
Loki's daughter hell was exiled to no
Finn home where she would rule over the
underworld
Fenrir was left in Asgard to be fostered
by the gods and your leg and was cast
into the ocean by Odin where he had
hoped the crashing waves would destroy
the Beast but to Odin's surprise human
gain consumed the ocean until he grew so
big that with his tail in his mouth he
could encircle the entire of Midgard
human gains physical appearance does
vary in some depictions he appears as a
monstrous snake and in others as a
serpent like dragon human Gann was
particularly hated by the god Thor and
there are numerous tales of altercations
between the two the hatred began when
Thor and a company of other gods visited
the land of the Giants where they came
across a huge castle the gates are so
large that the combined force of the
gods was not enough to get them open
luckily for the gods the bars are so big
they could squeeze through them upon
hearing that he had guests the king of
the castle told the gods that if they
expected his hospitality they would
first have to perform a series of feats
to impress him Thor was given the very
simple task of lifting the Kings pet cat
from the ground a task that was
considered so mundane that even the
children of the castle could do it
despite his immense strength Thor could
not complete this task only managing to
little one of the cat's paws above the
ground
back home in Asgard Thor was considered
more than capable of handling his drink
and so the King challenged him to drain
the castles great drinking horn once
again Thor was unable to complete the
task as the level of mead barely fell
below the rim
after these failures Thor was furious
and demanded to fight one of the Kings
fiercest warriors the King laughed and
mocked Thor telling him the early
opponent that would be a fair fight
would be the nurse of the castle Thor
begrudgingly accepted the challenge and
began to wrestle with the elderly woman
but even in this task he would fail the
next morning when leavin the castle the
king confessed the truth to Thor on the
rest of the gods the tasks that he had
given them were more than they appeared
the gods of Asgard had been tricked by
powerful enchantment and magic the
King's pet cat that Thor had been asked
to lift was in fact your leg and in
disguise and Thor had nearly pulled the
Great Serpent from the ocean bed that he
had been exiled to the great drinking
horn that Thor had drank from was
connected to the ocean and Thor nearly
drained the entire sea the old woman who
bested Thor was in fact old age a feat
that no one could conquer after hearing
the truth Thor turned and swung his
hammer at the king but he vanished along
with the castle from that day on Thor
swore revenge on the king and yeoman
gand but he had no idea where to find
either of them there are those who
believe that the giant King was in fact
Loki in disguise attempting to unleash
his son uelmen gand upon the world after
all
Loki was a renowned trickster and to
spell that strong that it could fool the
gods so easily would require the talents
of someone as powerful as Loki it wasn't
until Thor stumbled across a giant named
him eared who agreed to take him fishing
that Thor would stumble across your
Magan once again Thor had thrown a great
hook attached to a strong line over the
side of the boat in the hopes that the
bait would attract the attention of
young Magan
and that it did upon seeing the
monstrous serpent thought tucked on the
lion bringing your Magan to the surface
and a fierce battle between the two
commenced the giant was so terrified by
human gand and the rapidly sinking boat
that he cut the line returning the
serpent to the deep Thor was so incensed
by him ears actions that he swung his
hammer with such force the giant fell
overboard and drowned human again was so
terrified after his close encounter with
the God that he went into hiding and was
rarely seen by humans with Oh Thor did
not get revenge on the Midgard serpent
during their last encounter the two were
destined to meet again while the world
burns during Ragnarok Thor would
eventually slay human gand but during
the confrontation he suffered multiple
bites from the serpent human gains paws
and filled those wounds and would
eventually result in the death of Thor
human gand was a monster of such epic
proportions that it's hard to gauge his
true size and just like the rest of
Loki's children he was prophesized to
bring about the end of the world a
sequence of events that he most
certainly aided in I hope you guys
enjoyed covering some more Norse
mythology if you did then let me know
what you thought in the comments below
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained